Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
Vous connaissez l'histoire :
les dinosaures ont disparu il y a
66 millions d'années
à cause d'une météorite.
Mais ont-ils vraiment tous disparu ?
Aujourd'hui, on s'attaque à un cold case,
mais vraiment très, très cold.
Il y a 66 millions d'années,
la Terre est le théâtre d'un événement qui va bouleverser son histoire.
Une météorite géante file
dans sa direction
à la vitesse vertigineuse
de 72000 kilomètres par heure.
Cet énorme caillou de plus de dix
kilomètres de diamètre finit
sa course sur l'actuelle
péninsule du Yucatán, au Mexique.
Le choc est d'une violence inouïe :
il creuse un cratère de
180 kilomètres de diamètre.
La puissance dégagée par l'impact
représente l'équivalent
de plusieurs milliards de fois
celle de la bombe d'Hiroshima.
Ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'un tel objet s'écrase sur la Terre.
Mais cette fois,
les conséquences sont inédites :
la disparition des dinosaures, des animaux qui règnent sur notre planète
depuis des millions d'années.
Les dinosaures,
pas celui-ci, ceux-ci, ont vécu sur Terre
durant l'ère Mésozoïque.
C'est une période qui a commencé
il y a 250 millions d'années
et qui s'est terminée il y a 66 millions.
Avant, on disait l'ère secondaire.
Ils ont régné pendant plus de
160 millions d'années.
C'est une très longue période pendant laquelle les espèces qui nous sont
les plus familières
n'ont pas forcément cohabité.
Le T.Rex, par exemple, qui a vécu entre
68 et 66 millions d'années, n'a jamais croisé le diplodocus.
Et pour cause, il a disparu il y a
145 millions d'années.
Mais comment on sait tout ça ?
Il n'y a pas de pierre tombale !
Presque !
On connaît leur existence grâce aux nombreux squelettes fossilisés,
plus ou moins complets,
qui ont été retrouvés.
Le premier décrit comme tel,
a été découvert près d'Oxford,
en Angleterre, en 1815 :
il s'agit d'un Megalosaurus,
que les scientifiques de l'époque
ont pris pour un lézard géant.
Depuis, on en a déterré des milliers
un peu partout sur la planète.
Des noms que vous connaissez bien :
le Tyrannosaurus Rex,
le Tricératops, le Vélociraptor.
Mais ces spécimens ne constituent qu'une infime partie des dinosaures.
Dinosaure, étymologiquement : “terrible,
lézard” désigne non pas une espèce,
mais un super ordre
composé à ce jour de près
de 1900 espèces différentes.
Tenez, il y a autant de différences entre
le petit Compsognathus
de trois kilogrammes
à peine, le poids d'un chat.
Et l'Argentinosaurus
qui pouvait atteindre 100 tonnes
et mesurer 40 mètres de longueur
qu'entre un éléphant et un chien,
chez les mammifères.
Certains dinosaures étaient herbivores,
le Tricératops par exemple.
D'autres carnivores comme le T-Rex et
même omnivores comme le Galliminus.
Gallimimus, c'est mignon, non ?
Au début de la vidéo,
je vous ai dit que les dinosaures n'avaient
peut-être pas disparu.
C'est vrai que lorsque l'on observe
un crocodile ou un varan de Komodo,
on se dit qu'il
y a un petit air de famille.
D'abord, ce sont des reptiles.
Le crocodile est recouvert
d'écailles en kératine,
comme l'étaient partiellement
ou complètement les dinosaures.
Les œufs des uns et des autres possèdent une membrane amniotique
qui protège l'embryon.
Bah alors ?
Et bien, ça ne suffit pas
pour faire du crocodile
ou du dragon de Komodo un dinosaure.
Ce classement repose
sur des détails très spécifiques.
L'un d'eux se trouve au niveau
des membres inférieurs, sur l'humérus.
Cet os possède une crête particulière
qui n'existe pas chez les autres reptiles.
La position des pattes
est également différente.
Chez les dinosaures
elles sont placées sous le corps
et non sur les côtés
comme chez la plupart des reptiles.
Enfin, quand ils en possèdent,
les serpents ont perdu
les leurs depuis longtemps.
Mais chez leurs ancêtres, elles
se trouvaient bien sur les côtés du corps.
Quoi qu'il en soit,
ceux que l'on suspectait d'être
des descendants des dinosaures,
n'en sont pas.
Il faut chercher ailleurs.
Revenons à notre météorite.
Elle a percuté la Terre
il y a environ 66 millions d'années.
Dans l'imaginaire collectif,
tous les dinosaures auraient alors disparu
presque instantanément
sous la violence du choc.
Sauf que les dinosaures
n'ont pas disparu du jour au lendemain.
Ce processus a mis du temps,
beaucoup de temps, environ 32000 ans.
En réalité,
la disparition des dinosaures n'est
pas uniquement liée à l'impact
lui-même, mais aux
bouleversements du climat
et donc de l'écosystème,
qu’a engendré cet impact.
On l'a dit, il a creusé un cratère de
180 kilomètres de diamètre,
mais il déclenche aussi
de violents séismes
et des tsunamis gigantesques
qui, eux aussi, font beaucoup de victimes.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Le choc booste
l'activité volcanique de la Terre.
La quantité de CO2
que dégagent les volcans
dans l'atmosphère augmente,
provoquant des pluies acides.
L'effet de serre
devient lui aussi plus important.
Des méga incendies
se déclenchent un peu partout.
CO2 plus chaleur
entraîne aussi l'acidification des océans
et une perte de la biodiversité.
Parallèlement, un nuage de poussière enveloppe la Terre
et la plonge dans la pénombre.
Moins de lumière,
moins de photosynthèse,
les plantes ont beaucoup de mal à vivre.
L'herbe et les feuilles
se font de plus en plus rares.
Les herbivores trouvent de moins
en moins de nourritures et disparaissent
les uns derrière les autres,
puis les carnivores qui n'ont plus rien
à se mettre sous la dent.
Au final, 70% des espèces vivantes
sont rayées de la carte.
C'est ce qu'on
appelle : une extinction de masse.
70%, mais pas toutes.
Dans ce chaos, certains animaux
vont malgré tout réussir
à tirer leur épingle du jeu :
les mammifères.
Ils sont déjà présents au moment du choc. Et ceux qui vivent
partiellement sous terre vont pouvoir
survivre à ces bouleversements.
Ils sont charognards,
insectivores, granivores.
Certains ne sont pas plus gros
que des souris.
C'est le début de leur règne
qui se poursuit encore aujourd'hui.
Mais les mammifères ne sont pas les seuls à s’en être sortis
et à s'épanouir encore aujourd'hui.
Je vous l'ai dit au début de cette vidéo,
des dinosaures
ont survécu au cataclysme.
Regardez cette poule.
Et quoi, c’est une poule !
Un autre oiseau, ça sera plus clair :
le Casoar.
Et alors ?
Eh bien, comparons le squelette du Casoar avec celui de l’Anzu Wyliei
qui vivait il y a 66 millions d'années
au nord du continent américain.
Vous ne trouvez pas qu'il y a
un petit air de famille ?
Mais oui, du coup, ça ressemble aussi
au squelette d'une poule.
Evidemment,
ce lien de parenté entre la poule
et le T-Rex n'a pas été établi
tout de suite.
Un premier indice est déterré en 1861,
45 ans après la découverte
du premier fossile de dinosaure.
Vous vous souvenez ?
Le megalosaurus.
Cet indice, c’est l’archéoptéryx.
Le fossile fait penser à un dinosaure.
Il a des griffes, une mâchoire couverte
de dents acérées, mais il ressemble aussi
beaucoup à nos oiseaux avec
ses ailes couvertes de plumes.
C'est sûr, cet animal là savait voler.
Aucun doute, c'est l'ancêtre des oiseaux.
Mais les scientifiques s'interrogent.
Il y aurait-il un lien entre les dinosaures
et les oiseaux ?
Les seconds seraient-ils les
descendants des premiers ?
Pendant plus de 100 ans,
aucune réponse n'est venue.
Pas la moindre découverte
pour étayer cette théorie.
Et puis, en 1996, le verdict tombe enfin :
en Chine, dans la province du Liaoning,
les paléontologues
viennent de mettre au jour
un fossile de dinosaure très particulier :
il porte des plumes.
Il est très différent de l’archéoptéryx.
On l'appelle “dinosaure non aviaire”.
Mais cette découverte démontre
que les plumes constituent
un caractère physique
de beaucoup de dinosaures.
Le lien avec les oiseaux est établi.
Récemment, la découverte
de fossiles comblant
les trous de l'arbre généalogique
et de nombreuses analyses ADN
ont fini de prouver cette théorie.
Du coup, les scientifiques imaginent
différemment l'apparence des dinosaures.
Oubliez son allure de dragon,
le T.Rex était probablement
recouvert de plumes.
D'ailleurs,
certains chercheurs pensent même
que les dinosaures émettaient des sons
plus proches du cri d'un rapace ou du roucoulement d'un pigeon
que du rugissement d'un félin.
Ça fait moins peur, non ?
Sachez que des scientifiques cherchent
actuellement à réveiller certains
gènes endormis des poulets pour tenter
de redonner vie aux dinosaures.
Le projet s'appelle ironiquement : “Chickenosaurus”.
Alors, qu'en pensez-vous ?
Je suis sûr que désormais, vous regarderez différemment
les poules et les pigeons.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à liker et à vous abonner.
Excellente fin de journée.
Bonne semaine.
Et à dimanche prochain
pour un nouveau sujet épicurieux.